veste marron casque blanc voici le
numéro 2 de vallourec
il est venu pour parler du probable
licenciement de 80 de ses 204 salariés
répartis sur deux sites à cosne sur
loire et la presse n'est pas désirée
monsieur michel bonjour je suis gay en
france s'il vous plaît un mot quand même
un mot comme en attendant cet après midi
leur directeur général les ouvriers ont
débrayé dès 10 heures ce matin
c'est leur première action syndicale
depuis l'annnonce du plan de
restructuration de vallourec
un fabricant mondial spécialisé dans le
tube acier pour le forage pétrolier il
vient pas et des bonnes nouvelles il
vient juste nous essayer de nous faire
avaler la pilule on est de vous
confirmer la suppression des 80 emplois
voilà et nous faire avaler parce que
pour nous ça ça passe pas on sert de la
crise de la crise du pétrole pour
supprimer 80 emplois qui étaient prévus
je pense de longue date
la chute du prix du pétrole ou la
concurrence chinoise
voilà en effet les arguments de
vallourec pour supprimer plus de 1000
postes en france à l'horizon 2017 des
sites de production devrait également
fermer à l'heure actuelle on sait que le
site de koné est menacée de fermeture et
pour nous d'ici six mois un an ça sera
le site de ville show qui sera fermé par
la suite il joue la langue de boy nous
disent rien et il nous assène un nom ça
tout le temps dernier moment pour
l'heure rien n'a filtré de la réunion
entre direction et personnel
la prochaine action syndicale
d'envergure nationale se passera devant
le siège de vallourec à boulogne le 18
février prochain